this someone's going to have that
spectacle this woman takes vitamins
places out of New York City areas we
haven't seen them fight in before so we
can get these different flavors that's
going to add a freshness to it therefore
every sippy I'm trying to think of
something that we've never seen before
we're envisioning a big set piece on the
Washington Monument and as the lift goes
up with all of the classmates in the
bomb goes off my friends out there he
has to race to the Washington Monument
and it is crazy sequence of Peter
battling with their pipe never been the
type of also trying to save the day it's
going to be one of the most crazy
sequences I think Marv will have ever
done family it's just not just trying to
think of everything everything that we
do should be something new I think the
best way to go about it is to just be
the biggest fan I can be as well I have
a pretty good idea for a set piece on
the ferry
spider-man flips in Miami guys see you
legal what to do a ferry with the ten
thirty you missed it
you have a fight scene engine turns
around shoots of Webb mine Webb grenade
and the Staten Island Ferry it cracks in
ha
we have tanks and cars being possible
over the place to get a really long time
to rehearse and get it right and it's
awesome seems like on a movie of this
scale it's just remembering what it's
really about and making sure that you
never lose sight of that in the midst of
all the spectacle and movie magic Wow
all right let's do it when you make a
movie of this size and you know that
people are going to see it it's quite
daunting to make sure that you get it
right the thing audiences expect out of
this movie is the Spider Man picture
like never before very unique and a very
special movie was something really fun
to be involved in spider-man franchise
unbelief the evolution of spider-man the
Marvel Universe is the best thing Marvel
keeps an element of surprise it's going
to be good you know him too
the whole cast when we're all together
it's been such a delight since they want
Jacob and I hit it off immediately it's
probably the most important relationship
throughout the movie because he's the
only person who he confides in to talk
about being spider-man you spinach juice
waiter tarantula daddy longlegs brown
recluse so I almost seen that as a sort
of shrink you know someone he could just
really let out - what is it like being
things with nobody knows - it was crazy
super chording know zendaya plays a
character called Rochelle Gaza lizard
then why do you suppose but I don't have
any friends and she is a sort of weird
dorky kind of closed off character Emma
but she seems to follow peteyrin ed
around quite a lot she's really brought
something very cool to that character
and something very interesting and
unique we go already cuz I was hoping to
get in some like protesting Center one
of the embassies before dinner I don't
think I had like a big reaction to being
part of this movie until like Comic Con
I was like yo this is real cool it's
weird but he's super cool to me because
I feel like usually what she says it's
very real
can't believe you guys are this lame
party you're sure - one of the main
differences in the previous movies is
that we don't really have a bully his
main rival
they have this really funny back and
forth you can't just quit on a stroll up
and he welcomed back by everyone hey
welcome back Peter flash you're back to
first alternate what but he is so much
like himself in the movie it's crazy
Tony so funny I feel like I'm actually
becoming more and more like my character
I'm always like the guy that you're like
flash right yeah I didn't realize now
it's like uh-huh Tony right I grew up a
comic book nerd it's kind of like a
dream come true to be a part of
spider-man no no this is real real buddy
painted love interest in this movie is
live listen new top he's madly in love
with her she's the best looking go in
school he doesn't think that he can win
her over but just by being himself
it's just spider-man oh my god she's
crushing out spider-man no way beautiful
sweater man you say I'm spider-man you
can get any girl in the world you know
because you're a superhero and it's
quite interesting to play those scenes
knowing that you as a character have
that golden ticket but you can't play it
she's played by Laura Harrier who's
fantastic this is really important to
you this is my future
she is really driven and smart to the
senior so she's a bit old everyone else
is a sophomore so she's kind of like the
wise like popular girl in school
can't fail a week before nationals we've
had so much fun on set together we've
become really good friends it's just
like a great experience working with him
sorry gotta go
casting the character of Aunt May we are
guarded saying what wouldn't an aunt be
a little more like a big sister or
someone much closer to a mage then the
classic in the comic and then we just
started trying to think of the best
actresses we could think of and of
course Mercer told me it was one of the
first names that came up you have to
tell me what's going on just lay it out
Marisa Tomei just seems like she would
be Peter Parker's and like even our
writers when they were first pitching
their take on it they're like sync
Marisa Tomei not
that Tony Stark so everyone was like
yeah great she brings just so much life
to the character we have such a good
time on set with each other hope you got
a few good licks in yeah I got quite a
few minutes we friend is huge issues
okay big brother relationship is between
happy Hogan and pizza Happy's kind of
your point guy in this dough stress
amount young Peter Parker on behalf of
Tony Stark being vetted for membership
in the Avengers one of the great tropes
of coming-of-age stories is the older
sibling who's always there giving you a
hard time happy Hogan plays that role
what's that what are you wearing
I really like coming back in this
capacity of a guy who's sort of the next
generation looking after the new guy
being back with Tom Holland and Jon
Favreau this is crazy it reminded me of
that kind of first Ironman experience
don't running the office I was going to
do it I think that's amazing I thought
it would take like a huge amount of
persuading they're like nope we rang him
up we also he said yes
[Music]
he loved me he was like a happy little
kid on sex I'm clearly didn't say it's a
straightforward spider-man movie there's
always opportunities heavy hitters drop
and then to kind of support him I was
just trying to be like you I want you to
be better this one's particularly fun
for me till the old bands back together
again those two of them have you known
each other for nearly 10 years and they
know what to do and so it was really
nice to just be thrown into the deep end
role change and boys time we changed to
superhero movies only as good as Beverly
the vulture is played by none other than
Michael Keaton the main bad guy in the
movies going to be the motion the
vultures realize those with black mark
trading an MCU relics sell the stuff on
we're going to see that guys rise in
this criminal underworld business is
good the idea that there's detritus from
all the other movies that has settled
and that's hidden and that's out there
the vulture uses sort of an engineer who
built his wingsuit to transfer like that
stuff and do something with it
you don't understand how the world works
I found a really interesting approach to
what you all want to call a villain may
just corrupt things and like what he
sees as corruption I think you have a
pretty strong argument I think it was a
really cool thing for Keaton to do and
I'm sure he will not disappoint don't
you interfere with Lund business again
and everybody knew who he is perfect for
that role there was no one who could
play that role better than he could
everybody is Charlie a whole bunch of
new spider-man from the Disney Channel
one of the few advantages to Disney
buying Marvel there's a new round of the
spider-man giveaway - I'll announce a
winner at the end of this but really the
biggest thing with all this new footage
is our first look at Flash Thompson
talking in his relationship with Peter
how he's not quite the bullies that say
Joe Manganiello version of the character
was you seen with a science team here we
see so much more of them at high school
but you also remember that this aired on
the Disney Channel in that audience is
just way younger so they're marketing
this to people that are still in school
so of course they're going to show off
those parts of the film but you get a
little bit more vulture footage you
actually see a legit Iron Man suit that
he has that's left over so he has all
kinds of stark tech all kinds of [ __ ]
our e-tec that he uses to build his
flight suit in fun fact if you remember
the clip from earlier where he remote
turns on the bunt heater in spider-man
suit like oh yeah I totally built a seat
heater he's like oh that's so awesome he
builds software backdoors that Friday
can access so if someone stole an Iron
Man suit he could remote turn it off if
he wanted to so that makes me wonder if
there's going to be some sort of twist
with that with the vultures Tech in the
movie but they say he's a really badass
engineer and he feels like way too big
of a character for them to not let him
slink off so that he could always come
back in a new version of the sinister
six if they ever decide to do that let
me know what's your favorite part about
all this is a really cool special they
don't do this very often but they did it
for Civil War last year they'll probably
do a really big one for infinity war
next year so what's going to happen next
is there'll be new Game of Thrones and
they released a first look at the
Justice League intro from the Wonder
Woman movie they have like a brand new
DC movies intro and it has all these
characters that are going to be popping
up in there a couple surprises in the
background of it like Atrocitus so I'll
do a breakdown of that tomorrow along
with Game of Thrones but congratulations
to the new giveaway winner Cambodia's
Rex please private message me so I can
get your contact details there was a new
round in this video I'll just announce
the winner the next time I post a Marvel
video you can click here for part 1 of
the special and you can click here for
brand new Rick and Morty season
thank you so much for watching this I
thought I'll see you guys tonight